welcome to a recap of the 2014  sinquefield Cup the strongest chess  tournament in history well the  tournament started off with a bang for  the youngest player in the competition  Italian fabiano caruana who crushed  veselin topalov of Bulgaria in the first  round before displaying an amazing  pregame preparation against Maxine vashi  lagrave that wiped the frenchman off the  board I think it's a great start but I  have to stay vigilant to the end though  off to a slow start world champion  magnus carlsen offered his opinion about  his big matchup with the tournament  leader tomorrow sort of similar to the  Norway chess tournament he won his first  three games I'd grew my first two games  that I played him in the third round  with white and he almost won that game  as well before he ran out of steam and  and lost a couple games be sure to join  us for live coverage of the 2014 Singh  fill cup here in st. Louis at 150  central at us chess chance calm